I gotta tell you this new pope I think
he might be the coolest Pope ever he's
already made some really progressive
statements on topics like homosexuality
and abortion plus there were rumors he
sometimes this is in the news he
sometimes sneaks out of the Vatican at
night in disguise to feed the homeless
that's true just just last week Time
magazine named Pope Francis their Person
of the Year I was I'm so intrigued by
this guy yeah okay one guy that's fine
magazines are dying I was so intrigued I
invited the Pope to our show to
congratulate him and guess what this
Pope is so cool he texted me and said
sure why not
so please welcome His Holiness Pope
Francis
[Applause]
whoa cool alright I gotta tell you it is
an honor to have you on the show again
your holiness uh uh Fran Fran I gotta
tell you I am triple psyched to be back
in the cone zone that's fine thank you
besides I was right around the corner in
the parking lot selling bandanas hashtag
Pope's gotta eat all right
well first of all I had to ask is this
the disguise you wear when you're out
visiting the homeless people what no man
this is my Pope attire oh all right
awkward yeah I'm sorry I thought it was
no no harm no foul these people
vestments can get kind of snug
downstairs and I prefer to stay in the
hotel with the largest ballroom if you
know what I mean
hashtag talking about the little bishop
okay we got it you're you're pretty cool
yeah and I'm sure you're busy but before
you go I want to congratulate you on
being voted Time magazine's Person of
the Year oh thank you you know that was
pretty trippy and you know what was an
even bigger honor in November I got
voted High Times magazines best bud of
the month really oh oh there you are
Wow
[Applause]
strictly medical folks strictly medical
no dealing just healing nice is a guy
plus I got to hang out at Sundance with
my spiritual adviser Willem Dafoe
we even got matching tats you got tats
with one to follow amazing hopes got a
role happy holidays everybody yeah
hit me up on snapchat
you